こんにちは
はじめしゃちょーです
今日は面白いものを見つけました
こちらっ！
プルルルルッ
バーン！
メガバルーン！
ジャイアントサイズ
３ｍのバルーン
こういう感じでですね、すごい巨大なバルーンがあるんですけれども、
なんとこちら、最大約３０ｍ飛ぶ！
キャーーー！
という訳でまずは一回このメガバルーン、作ってみましょう
作り方も結構簡単みたいです。
まず外で走ってパララッてしろ 的なね。OK。
うわ...なに...
でっかくね、え、ちょっと待って
けっこうでかいよ
バルーンを広げて空気を入れます。走ってね。
いってきます
♪～（クシコスポスト）
どうすか
目まわった
で、ある程度空気が入ったら息を吹き込んでください、と。
めっちゃシンナー吸ってるみたいじゃんｗ
は）どうどうどうどうどう？
ま）めっちゃ長いね
は）いい感じじゃない？
ま）うん
うわ、もうやばいよまさき、これ。
見て見て見て
え、やばくねっ
このなんか付属していたゴムで留めます。
よし。
はい、メガバルーンの完成です。
え、やばくない？
はい
マスオTＶ笑
横になってみても、僕と全く同じサイズでございます
はい、こんなサイズ感になっております
投げると、30ｍくらい飛ぶと書いてあったので
ちょっと、早速投げてみましょう
あはっはっｗｗ　うぉおｗｗ
ちょっと待ってｗｗｗｗ
え！？
は）え、え...凄くねｗ
ま）結構すごいね
は）結構飛んだよ、まってマジで凄い
うわ、やばい、うわ
おらぁ！！
うわぁ..はっはぁｗｗ
23歳でした
優しく落ちるね
かなり飛ぶことが分かったと思いますが！
僕は、ただのメガバルーンじゃ満足しない
今回、メガバルーンに使用する特殊なアイテムはこちら！
あっ！！はいこちら
ヘリウムガス
僕は思ってしまった
ただの空気ですら、あれだけ飛ぶメガバルーン
もし、彼（メガバルーン）の中に、このヘリウムガスを入れると
もう、大気圏行きますよ
いや、普通の空気の重さですら、あれだけ飛ぶってことは
多分ヘリウムガスを入れると、マジな方で500ｍぐらい飛びますよ
こういくと思うんだよね
上に上がってくよｗｗ
ヘリウムガスっていうのはあれです、風船とか浮かすときに使われるガス
空気よりかなり軽いので、ひょっとしたらメガバルーンがギガバルーンになるかもしれ・・・
ちょっと足りなかったみたい
完全に持ち手になっちゃてるよ
ハァクションッッ！！
はい、というわけで少し小さくなりましたが
ヘリウムガス入りメガバルーン完成しました
早速飛ばしていこうと思います
ではいこう
いきます
はい、今のでわかったと思うが
ヘリウムガスを入れても大して変わらない
むしろ悪化している
原因なんですけども、ヘリウムは上にいく力があるので
軽いんだよね
多分空気の重さがあったから、さっきみたいにメガバルーンは結構飛んだと思うんですけど
なので、次はですねまだあまりの部分が結構あるので
ヘリウムガスと空気を混ぜて入れれば多分、最初のメガバルーンよりもっと飛ぶんじゃないのかと思うので
ちょっとこのあまりの部分のところも空気を入れて
満パンにしてもう一回飛ばしてみようと思います
できたーー！！
空気とヘリウムガスの合体バージョンメガバルーン
これなら間違いなく飛ぶだろう
空気ほど重くもなく、ヘリウムほど軽くはない
完璧だ
では早速飛ばしてみようと思います
いくぞ！！
うるぁああ！！
は）めっちゃ飛んでない？　　ま）めっちゃ飛んだよ今
は）成功したらしたで、オチがねぇーんだよな
ま）ｗｗｗ
ま）イタッ
～♪ED♪～